the golden ticket is what i'm announcing
that's right
like a good neighbor my friends at state
farm are helping me
give a select few the chance to
virtually
meet me sona and of course girly but i
want to
just really emphasize me you're going to
meet me
and sona and garlic and maybe even be
featured right here on conan o'brien
needs a friend
all right here's how it works we're
going to be releasing
these golden tickets on team coco's
instagram
on tbs and of course right here on my
podcast
uh you never know where these golden
tickets are gonna be where they're gonna
show up
so you have to pay attention then when
you see when you have to act quick
or does it act quickly i think it's act
quickly that's what i advert
says right here act quick someone
screwed up exactly anyway
so you just might be one of the lucky
few all right head to teamcoco.com
golden ticket for more details